སུ་ལ་ཀློག
ཀུན་བཟང་། ད་ཡིན་ད། དང་པོ།
ཀུན་བཟང་དང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། ཁོ་གཉིས་གཅིག་གིས་ར།
དཔེ་དེབ་མང་པོ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ང་ལ་དཔེ་མང་པོ་དེབ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་གཉིས་གིས་དེབ་ཀློག་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས།
ཁོ་རང་དེབ་ཆེན་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། དེབ་མང་པོ་གཅིག་ཁེར་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་གཉིས་གཉིས་གིས་ར་ཨ་མ་ང་ལ་རྡོ་རག་སོང་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་གཉིས་གཉིས་གིས་ར་ལག་པ་འགྲམ་ལ་རྡོ་གཅིག རྡོ་རིལ་རིལ་གཅིག་རག་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོ་གཉིས་གཉིས་ལ་རྡོ་རིལ་རིལ་གཅིག་འདུག་ག ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་གཉིས་གཉིས་ར་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
རྡོ་འདི་ལ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་རང་མགོ་རྡོ་བརླགས་རེད་(ད)།ང་གཅིན་པ་གཏང་དགོས་ཡོད།
ང་སྒྲུང་ཀློག་ཡ་ཡིན། མ་བྱེད་ད། ཕལ་རྒྱུགས་ད་བྱས།
ང་རྒན་ལགས་་མ་རེད་(ད)།
སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།དང་པོ་ནས་ར་ཁ་གཅིག་གི་ཡོད་རེད་ད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། དང་པོ་ནས་ར།
རྡོ་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་རྡོ་འདི་འདྲས་འདྲ་བོ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།བལྟ་ཨ། རིལ་རིལ་
རིལ་རིལ་འདི་འདྲས་བཤད་ཚར་སོང་ང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་བྱིའུ་གཅིག་འདི་འདྲས་དགོས་རེད་(ད)།
ད་ཡིན་ད།
གཅིག གཉིས། གསུམ། ཀློག་ཡ་ཡིན་ད།
འདི། བྱེའུ་གཅིག་བསད་འདུག་ག བྱེའུ་གཅིག་འདུག་ག
ཨ་ཡོ།
Oh no!!!
ད་ཡིན་ད། དེ་རིང་ང་ཚོ་སྐྱིད་པ་ལ། སང་ཉིན་གུང་གསེང་། ཞོགས་པ་ང་ཚོ་ལ་ནི།
ད་ཡིན་ད། ད་ཡིན་ད་བྱས། ད་དེ་ཡིན་ད།
ད་ཡིན་ད། དང་པོ་ནས་ར། དགེ་བཤེས་ལགས་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
དང་པོ་བྱེའུ་གཅིག་དགེ་བཤེས་ལགས་ཕར་རྒྱུགས་ལབ་རེད་སྒོ། ང་རེའི་དགེ་བཤེས་ལགས།
དགེ་བཤེས་ལགས་འདུག ང་རེའི་ཁ་གྱི་དང་པོ་སྔན་མ་གཅིག་གྲོགས་མོ་ཆགས་རེད་(ད)།
དགེ་བཤེས་ལགས་སྔན་མ་གཅིག་གྲོགས་མོ་ཆགས་རེད་ང་།
མིག་ཆུ་ཤོར་སོང་།
ག་རེ། གྲི་དེ་ག་བར་འདུག་བལྟ་དགོས།
ད་གཞས་གཏང་ཡ་རེད་(ད)།
ཞོགས་པ་ང་ཚོ་ལ་ནི་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ག་འགྲོ།
ཞོགས་པ་ང་ཚོ་ལ་ནི།
ཞོགས་པ་ང་ཚོ་འགྲོ་ནས་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ག་འགྲོ།
སྲུ་མོ་ཆོས་སྒྲོན་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་འགྲོ་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།སྲུང་མོ་ཆོས་སྒྲོན་དང་ང་རེའི་ཨ་མ་ཡི་ཤེས་ད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
སྐྱག་པ་གཅིག་འགྲོ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ལམ་ཁ་ལ་སྐྱག་པ་ཆེན་པོ་གཅིག་འདི་འདྲས་འགྲོ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་ད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། ལག་པ་འདི་འདྲས་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ལག་པ་གཉིས་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།རྐང་པ་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།འདི་འདྲས་"ཛོམ་བེ་"འདྲ་བོ་དེ་འདྲས་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
ཁོ་རང་མིག་ཆུ་ཤོར་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་རང་ཨ་མ་ཡོད་མ་རེད་ར། ཁོ་རང་ནང་ལ་ཡོད་་མ་ར། ཁོ་རང་ཨ་ཕ་ཡོད་མ་ར།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་མིག་ཆུ་ཤོར་རེད་(ད)།ཨ་ཕ་དགོས་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་ར། ཨ་ནེ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ཨ་ནེ་གཅིག
ཨ་ནེ་རྒྱག་པ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ཨ་ནེ་རྒྱག་པ་ར།
སྲུ་མོ་ཆོས་སྒྲོན་རྒྱག་པ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། སྲུ་མོ་ཆོས་སྒྲོན་ངུས་རེད་(ད)།སྲུ་མོ་ཆོས་སྒྲོན་འདི་འདྲས་
སྲུ་མོ་མ་རེད་(ད)།ང་རེའི་ཨ་མ་ཡོད་༼ར༽། ང་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྲུ་མོ་སྒྲོན་ར་
ཨ་་ག་ལེ་ག་ལེ་ཁྲིད་ད་ང་རེའི་ཨ་མ་ཡིས། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽འགྲོ་སོང་ད།
ད་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽འགྲོ་སོང་ད།
ད་རྫོགས་སོང་། དཔེར་ན་དང་པོ་ནས་
ད་ཡིན་ད་ཁྱེད་རང་།
ག་བ་འགྲོ་སོང་། ཨ་ཉོག་ག་བ་འགྲོ་སོང་།
ཨ་ཉོག་ག་བ་འགྲོ་སོང་། ཨ་ཉོག་ག་རེ་བྱས་སོང་།
ལུག་ཆུང་ཆུང་དགོས་ལབ་སོང་ངས། ང་བལྟ་ག་འགྲོ་དགོས།
སྒྲུང་ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་སྟོན་ད།
སྒྲུང་གཅིག བལྟད་མོ་མ་ལྟ་ཤི།
ཁྱེད་རང་རྨོ་མོ་ཡིན་པ། ཁྱེད་རང་ཁྱེད་རང་འདྲ་བོ་གཅིག
སྒྲུང་ཀློག་དགོས་རེད་(ད)།
ཀློག
ཀློག་ཚར་ནས་ར། ཁྱེད་རང་ཕ་གིར་ལེན་ཨ་དེབ་གཞན་པ། ཡར་ལངས་ནས་ལེན་ཨ།
ཀློག་ཚར་ཡིན་པ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽འདི་རྩེ།
རྩེ་ཨ། ཁྱེད་རང་རྩེ།
ང་ལབ་དགོས། འདི་འདྲས་ར། ཁོ་རང་འདི་ལ་ཡག་པོ་བཞག འདི་ལ་འདི་འདྲས་བཞག འདི་འདྲས། འདི་འདྲས།
འདི་འདྲས། འདི་འདྲས། འདི་འདྲས། མ་རེད། འདི་ཞུ་ཡ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
"ཁོ་རྫི་"ཁེར་ཡོང་དགོས་བས། "ཁོ་རྫི་"ཆུང་ཆུང་གཉིས་ཁེར་ཡོང་དགོས་བས།
འདི་སྤྲད་ད། གཅིག
འ་་ཁོ་རང་ང་རྒན་ལགས་རེད་(ད)།རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་བྱེད་མཉའ།
ཁྱེད་རང་ཁོ་གཉིས་གི། ཝེ་སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་ཤི།
རྩེད་མོ་མ་རྩེ་ཤི། མར་གསད་ཤི།
ག་འདིས།
ཁོ་རང་རྨོ་མོ་རེད་བ།
རྨོ་མོ་ཡིན་པ། ཁྱེད་རང་རྨོ་མོ་ཡིན་པ།
ད་ཡིན་ད། དཔེ་ཆུང་ཆུང་རེད།
ཁྱེད་རང་གི་པེ་ཤག་མ་རེད་(ད)།ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་རྔན་པ་
རྒན་ལགས་གིས་ར། རྒན་ལགས་གཅིག་གིས་རྔན་པ་ཁེར་སོང་།
དགོས་བས།
ཁྱེད་རང་འདི་ནང་ལ་རྩེད་མོ་རྕེ་ཡ་ཡོད། དགོས་བས། དེབ་རེད།
འདི་འདྲས་ལབ། མོ་ཊ། མོ་ཊ།
མ་རེད་(ད)།ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་དེ་རྩེ། འདི་རྩེ་ཚར་ཡིན་པ། རྒན་ལགས་གིས།
ཁོ་རང་ཚོ་ཀློབ་བཅུག་ལོ།  སྐད་མ་རྒྱག་ལོ།
འདི་ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་འདི་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ། ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་ཚར་ཡིན་པ།
ཁྱེད་རང་ག་རེ་བྱས།
ཁྱེད་རང་མར་སྡོད་ཤི
བྲོ་བ་ལྟ་ལ་མར་སླེབས།
དང་པོ་ནས་ར། ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་སྒྲུང་ཀློག་ཤི།
རྔན་པ་གཅིག་སྤྲད་དགོས། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་གཅིག་སྤྲད་དགོས། ཁྱེད་རང་གིས་ཀློག་ཚར་ཡིནཔ། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་གཅིག་སྤྲད་དགོས།
འདི་དགོས་བས། ཁྱེད་རང་ལ་འདི་དགོས་བས།
ཁྱེད་རང་ལ་འདི་དགོས་བས།
ཁྱེད་རང་གཉིས་འཁྲུག་པ་མ་རྒྱག ང་ལ་གཉིས་ཡོད
འདི། འདི་ལ་འདུག་ག
འདི་རེད།
འངི་མ་ཏརང་ང། འདི་རེད། འདི། འདི་ལ་ནག་པོ་རེད།
འདི་སྨྱུ་གུ་རེད།
འདི་ཁེར་ཤོག་ད།
ཁྱེད་རང་འདི་ལ་གཉིས་ཡོད། ཁྱེད་རང་འདི་ལ་བྱེད་ཡ་རེད། འདི་ལ་བྱེད་ཡ་མ་རེད་(ད)།
འདི་ཉར།